You just don't want someone
acting radically around
you like and you know that.
So he walked down Bluer.
Okay.
And there's people there that
should really be institutionalized,
but we deinstitutionalized them all
so they could be free and free to be,
you know,
suffering and malfunctioning
out on the street.
That's what the freedom ended up being.
But you know,
when you walk by someone like that who's
moderating away to the voices
in his head and you know,
maybe
striking out against whatever it is
that's plaguing him and you will make eye
contact.
You might even go across the street,
you're certainly going
to give him a wide berth.
You're going to keep a distance between
him and you and you're going to hope
that you don't attract his
attention because he's not
in the dominance hierarchy
and you don't know what
the hell he might do.
And that's unexplored territory too.
That's another way of thinking about it.
Like
we inhabit time and space,
not just space and not just time.
We didn't have it time and space and
our territory's our spacial temporal.
We're here now and this is safe now and
it's safe partly because of the physical
structure and it's working,
but it's also safe because none of
you are manifesting peculiar behavior.
But if you started to
manifest peculiar behavior,
if you stood up and started muttering or
yelling or maybe attacking someone next
to you,
all the rest of you would freeze first
because then all of a sudden this would
be unexplored territory.
The match between what you want,
which is a peaceful lecture
that you hope has some content.
The match between what you want
and what's happening has vanished.
And so then you're not,
you don't know where you are.
And so then what do you do when
you don't know where you are?
What do you do when you
don't know what to do?
Well,
if your computer,
you just crash,
but you know what good is that to you?
You're just going to die.
That isn't helpful.
Okay?
You freeze first and then maybe you
cautiously cautiously attend or maybe you
don't.
Maybe you just keep your damn eyes averted
and you sit there and you hope that
no one notices you.
That's a predator.
That's a prey response,
right?
That's like a rabbit frozen when it
thinks that Fox is looking at it.
And we were prey animals for a long time.
There was a cat that
they recently discovered,
a prehistoric cap that had this bottom
single tooth and they found out that it a
human skull fit right inside its mouth.
And so it could grab you here and
Pierce the back of your skull with its,
with its single tooth.
And that's what it was evolved for.
So,
you know,
okay,
it's under such conditions.
We evolved and we're predators obviously,
but we're tasty predators.
And so other things were
perfectly happy to eat us.
Okay.
And so when you're aware
you don't know what to do,
you act like a prey animal and that's
probably what you should do because maybe
if you keep your head
down and shut the hell up,
there won't be any attention
to attracted to you.
And maybe you'll get through it.
You know,
you might decide,
unlikely to intervene
and take the guy down,
but,
but you would be the exception
rather than the norm.
And it's unsurprising.
Okay.